Uh, we also know the position of, uh, Kyiv, they kept saying that they want negotiations and kind of asked for it, and now they have made an official decision that prohibits these negotiations. Well, what can we talk about here, we always said that we are open to us. even after certain agreements were reached in Istanbul, I actually almost initialed the agreements to you, everything, as soon as the troops left Kyiv, the desire to negotiate the Kyiv authorities immediately disappeared, and everything that is happening today is unpleasant, to put it mildly, but it’s all the same we would get a little later, only in the worst conditions for us. So we act correctly. bringing some troops into direct contact into direct contact. A clash with the Russian army is a very dangerous step that could lead to a global